for the last couple of years tesla has
been slowly driving down the price of
their vehicles
as their manufacturing and battery
efficiency improves
recently they even unveiled their plans
to have a 25
000 ev rolling out in a few years
despite this
tesla only plans on selling consumer
cars for another 5 to 10 years
before stepping out and here's why
starting off elon musk believes that the
value of full self driving
is worth a lot more than the ten
thousand dollars they are charging for
the development version
today in fact musk believes that full
autonomy software with regulatory
approval will cost
well over one hundred thousand dollars
but
why the drastic price increase tesla has
already made great strides towards full
self-driving
and they are no doubt in the tail end of
development today
so it's unlikely to cost them over nine
times more to finish development
now of course regulatory approval and a
refined product themselves
hold value but those don't add nine
times value for the average customer
with that being said this price increase
has less to do with recouping
development costs
and more to do with accounting for
opportunity cost
sure the average customer likely won't
get an extra 90
000 in value once full self driving is
finished and approved
but tesla and business owners will
after receiving regulatory approval
tesla plans on rolling out the robot
taxi service
which as the name suggests is just taxis
that drive themselves
and though very simple in theory unlike
uber and lyft
tesla's robo taxi business will likely
be very profitable
as they don't have to pay for a driver
in fact
a few years ago elon musk announced that
they expect each robo taxi to pull in a
gross profit of 30 000
per year driving 90 000 miles annually
considering that they expect their cars
to last 1 million miles
this roughly gives them 10 years to
profit from each robo taxi
in that decade they can expect about 300
in gross profit from each robo taxi as
you can see
sign this opportunity through a 30 to 50
000 car
makes no sense instead of selling the
car to you
they can add it to their robo taxi
network and make back that money
in less than two years aside from this
though full self driving
may not be worth anywhere near one
hundred thousand dollars for the average
person
for several businesses this price is a
steal for instance
one hundred thousand dollars is not bad
for retail chains like walmart
and sam's club and logistics companies
like ups
and fedex for them full self-driving
only costs a few years of driver salary
but provides
several years of driver value not to
mention
they don't have to deal with their
drivers having to sleep or eat or
perform
any other bodily functions aside from
charging
these vehicles can just keep going
considering this long-term vision
why is tesla even bothering with a
budget car
previously reducing prices could be
explained by getting their cars to more
customers
and collecting more data in order to
better develop full self-driving
technology
but today tesla has already gathered
billions of miles of data
in fact they reached 3 billion
self-driven miles way back in april
and they're currently growing at
billions of miles per year
as a result the budget car is not
intended to really accelerate full
self-driving development
or anything like that there are two main
reasons that tesla
is going ahead with the super budget car
the first of which being proof of
concept
tesla's mission is to accelerate the
world's transition to sustainable energy
and consequently proving that a
practical budget ev
is possible to mass produce is very
important in pushing forward
said transition by successfully
producing such a car
tesla would be showing other car
manufacturers like gm
toyota and honda that it is not only
possible
but that there is more than enough
demand for such a vehicle
aside from proof of concept the second
major goal with the budget ev
is increasing production in order to
really make a dent in the market using
robo taxis
tesla will have to produce millions of
cars per year
and scaling up to such numbers privately
is extremely difficult
though robo taxis will be very
profitable that's over several years
initially tesla will have to front the
cost of all of the cars they produce
currently tesla's gross profit margin on
their cars is 27.7 percent
elon musk has made it his goal to make
this number 30
and looking at the trend over the past
few quarters
it does seem like they'll succeed in
accomplishing this goal
but we do have to keep something in mind
this
overall gross profit margin for their
vehicles is boosted by the sale of their
high margin vehicles
like the model s and model x though
these models only account for a small
portion of their sales
it likely accounts for a much larger
portion of their profits
as a result it's unlikely that tesla's
overall gross profit margin
will carry over to their budget model as
well but
we'll give them the benefit of the doubt
to really illustrate how expensive
deploying robot taxis will be
even if tesla is able to carry over a 30
gross profit margin onto their budget 25
car each car will cost them 17
500 to manufacture to deploy just
one million robo taxis which is a very
small amount in the grand scheme of
things
tesla will have to invest 17.5 billion
dollars
considering this tesla will have to
front tens of billions of dollars
if not hundreds of billions of dollars
to get the robo taxi network
actually up and running with that being
said they would prefer to reduce
as many costs elsewhere as possible one
of these costs
is of course building factories and
improving efficiency of said factories
each gigafactory cost tesla roughly 5
billion dollars to build
with the berlin gigafactory coming in at
4 billion euros
and the shanghai gigafactory coming in
at 5 billion
let's say that the funding of 4
gigafactories is already complete
the fremont factory giga shanghai and
the upcoming factories in berlin
and austin if each of these factories
can produce 500 000 vehicles per year
as they suggest those factories together
give us 2 million vehicles per year
to really make an impact in the market
tesla will likely want to scale up to 10
million cars per year
which is how much toyota and volkswagen
each produce
annually in order to get such numbers
tesla will have to increase their
production capability
by another 8 million or add another 16
gigafactories
at 5 billion a factory that's another 80
billion
in upfront costs as you can see that's a
very hefty bill
and a perfect way to subsidize it is by
selling budget cars that appeal to a
wide audience
so the purpose of the 25 000 car is to
one
prove concept and demand and two scale
up manufacturing capability
and improve efficiency on top of this
the budget car
may be a perfect candidate to be used in
the robo taxi network
and continuing to sell it while building
the network may turn out to be a great
revenue source to actually fund the robo
taxi network
so that's why tesla plans to stop
selling cars
but is still going ahead with the budget
model anyways
but really when can we actually expect
this transition to take place
well tesla may go ahead and launch a few
hundred thousand robo taxis
or even a few million robo taxis within
a few years
after receiving regulatory approval
however
their move away from actually selling
consumer cars likely won't happen
until they reach full scale or about 10
million cars plus per year
right now they're building roughly 2
gigafactories per year
and this is expected to scale up to 3 or
but to be conservative we'll say that
they only had 2 factories per year
at that rate tesla should reach a total
of 20 giga factories in 2028
or 2029 or basically by the end of the
decade
and that also gives us plenty of time to
actually finish development of full self
driving
and get approval so we may see the
transition
begin in about 2030. once the transition
begins
we'll say that all the gross profits
they receive from selling their cars
goes into the robo taxi network to be
conservative once again
we'll say that the average selling price
of tesla's cars is thirty thousand
dollars
as sales will likely skew towards the
budget model as we move forward
with the 30 gross profit margin that
means that tesla will be able to fund
one robo taxi car
for every 2.33 cars they sell
in other words when producing 10 million
cars per year
tesla can afford to have up to 3 million
of these cars be robo taxis
in the second year however with 3
million robo taxis bringing in gross
profit of 30 000 per year
each tesla will enjoy a massive gross
profit
of 90 billion dollars or enough to fund
4.2 million more robo taxis
annually if tesla was super aggressive
with this transition
they can likely afford to complete it
within three years
but assuming they opt for a more smooth
transition
three to five years seems more
reasonable so maybe around 2033-2035
if tesla is able to get approval and
scale up earlier
this may be as early as 2028 to 2030
but the more likely case is in the 2030s
anyways after this transition tesla will
be able to exponentially raise their
profits
prior to the transition selling 10
million cars with 30 gross profit
would have led to one-time profit of 90
billion dollars
injecting 10 million cars into the
robo-taxi market however
is projected to come out to 300 billion
dollars in profit
annually for the next decade clearly
it's no wonder why tesla would prefer
the latter
but in the meantime there's still quite
a bit of time left
to buy tesla will you guys be buying a
tesla before they start this transition
comment that down below also drop a like
if the latest beta release gives you
hope that autonomy will come
sooner rather than later and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one